وواضح مما تفضلت به انه هذه الانتخابات لن
تكون انتخابات عاديه ستكون صعبه هل ما
ذكرتيه هو ما يجعل هذه الانتخابات مختلفه
عن سابقاتها بشكل او
باخردي في تاريخ الانتخابات الامريكيه يشم
الى انه عندما يكون هناك حزب ما في البيت
الابيض يفوز غريمه باغلبيه الكونجرس لكن
هذه المره نحن على يقين بان الارقام تشير
الى ان الامريكيين سيوجهون رساله قاسيه
لديمقراطيين مفادها ان الناخبه غير راض
بالمره عن سياساتهم لذلك نحن نترقب اداء
قويا جدا من الجمهوريين في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه وانه على الرئيس ان يفهمه ان رفض
هذه السياسات التي تحدثنا عنها سواء ان
تعلق الامر بالسياسه الخارجيه او الداخليه
او ملف الطاقه والامن وكارثه افغانستان
وتدمير علاقات مع حلفائنا وايضا ما يحدث
في ايران التي يتظاهر شعبها منذ سته
اسابيع من دون ان ارى موقفا واضحا وقويه
من البيت الابيض يدعم الشعب الايراني وهو
في الشارع كل هذه الامور الى جانب كيفيه
ادارته للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه التي لا
نعرف حتى الان متى ستنتهي كل هذه اخطاء
كبيره من اداره ونحن نعتقد ان المواطن
الامريكي سيبلغه بوضوح وباعلى صوت انه ضد
هذه السياسات وان وعندما يعيد الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه فانه يعبر بذلك عن سخطه من
سياسات الحزب الديمقراطي والاداره الحاليه
وانه يتعين عليه في السنتين المقبل اعاده
الجمهوريين